bonjour
je suis très heureuse et très émue
d'être devant vous aujourd'hui merci à
mathod chorale salimatou pour pour cette
invitation au stade elle donc nous
sommes ici au salon des entrepreneurs à
conakry je m'appelle donc ce halimatou
diallo j'ai 40 ans je suis mère de cinq
enfants qui sont âgés
qui sont âgés respectivement de 11 ans
et demi huit ans et demi je précise
l'aïe nuit parce que c'est très
important pour un pour elle huit ans et
demi cinq ans et demi deux ans et demi
et un petit bébé de deux mois et demi
et ce petit bébé vous avez entendu
d'ailleurs pleurer tout à l'heure dans
la salle c'est lui il est venu se tenir
c'est à dire sa maman alors je vais pas
vous présenter mon parcours
universitaire ni vous présenter mon
parcours professionnel
est-ce que ça c'est assez facile pour
vous de le trouver vous pouvez les
regarder sur linked in ou sur google je
suis venu ici aujourd'hui pour vous
parler de ce sujet qui est passionnant
qui suit si beaucoup de débats beaucoup
de controverses qui est celui de l'
équilibre difficile à trouver entre la
vie privée et la vie professionnelle
pour moi cet équilibre en fait dont on
parle est un mythe c'est un mythe qu'on
va déconstruire ensemble aujourd'hui
parce que en fait c'est très difficile
de parler de cet équilibre puisqu'en
fait il n'existe pas tout simplement
donc on va aborder plusieurs plusieurs
aspects et plusieurs idées reçues sur
c'est sur 7
cette
expression pardon et qu'on va
déconstruire un ensemble
le contexte du président en fait qui
nous a tous frappé récemment a permis à
chacun d'entre nous de prendre
conscience d'un certain nombre de
réalités parce qu'on nous ramenant à la
maison avec le travail à distance pour
beaucoup d'entre nous ça nous a fait
réaliser que en fait on n'avait qu'une
seule vie il n'y a pas d'un côté la vie
privée et la vie professionnelle il
avait dû prendre en compte le travail à
distance pour nos professionnels il a
fallu prendre en compte l'école à
distance pour pas mal d'enfants qui ont
été obligés de retourner à la maison et
donc que ce soit pour les hommes ou pour
les femmes c'est une période qu'on vient
de traverser qui nous a interpellés et
qui a fait qu'on a dû s'interroger je
parle en tout cas pour moi
particulièrement sur ce que ça
signifiait travail et avoir des enfants
avoir une famille et en même temps
rester chez soi et essayer de concilier
les deux parce que d'un d'un jour à
l'autre finalement ces retraits dans une
situation où les écoles ont été fermées
je me souviens c'était arrivé ça ait
annoncé un dimanche soir et le lundi 7
et harmonie avait il y avait plus
d'école donc on a dû rester chez nous et
on s'est retrouvé donc moi en
l'occurrence je ne sors avec mes quatre
enfants à l'époque parce que le bébé
n'était pas né et je me suis demandé
comment j'allais réussir à gérer un
petit peu tout ça mais bon finalement je
pense qu'on est tous ressortis un peu
grandi de cette période qui vient qui
vient de passer et aujourd'hui on
regarde l'avenir avec un petit peu plus
d'espoir pour les mois à venir
alors le premier mythe que je pense
qu'il faut déconstruire c'est qu'il ya
donc d'un côté la vie privée de l'autre
côté la vie professionnelle comme je le
disais tout à l'heure il n'y a qu'une
seule vie on n'a qu'une seule vie quand
on n'est pas bien à la maison ma on
ramène ça au travail on le veuille ou
non c'est le principe des vases
communicants quand on n'est pas bien au
travail on le ramène à la maison on peut
pas être bien
aucun des deux ne fonctionne pas donc
c'est important de garder à l'esprit que
on n'a qu'une vie et qu'on est obligé de
concilier les deux finalement et c'est
ça qui fait en fait de nous ce qu'on ait
aujourd'hui mais il faut d'abord savoir
dans quoi elle conçoit réalise le mieux
moi je porte absolument pas de jugement
justement pour les femmes qui font le
choix de ne pas avoir de carrière
professionnelle parce que en fait on
fait des choix en fonction de ce qui
nous correspond nous personnellement et
donc il faut pour cela il faut vraiment
apprendre à bien se connaître
l'idée reçue numéro deux c'est qu'il
faut sacrifier l'un au profit de l'autre
qu'on peut pas tout avoir moi je suis
pas d'accord du tout je pense qu'on peut
tout avoir quand on est une femme
spécialement quand on est une femme
africaine on peut tout avoir il suffit
de pouvoir s'organiser et surtout comme
je disais encore une fois c'est une
question de choix je vais vous raconter
un petit peu comment je suis arrivé ici
devant vous quand j'ai été contacté par
le cden pour venir participer à ce salon
c'était fin mars initialement donc la
première date qui avait été qui avait
été prévue et à ce moment là bas j'étais
très proche de mon accouchement si vous
faites un peu de maths c'est facile
j'étais sur le point d'accoucher et donc
je je ne voulais pas renoncer à cette
opportunité parce que je trouvais que
c'était quelque chose de très
intéressant à faire mais je ne pouvais
pas venir parce que j'étais à l'étranger
et donc je leur ai proposé de le faire à
distance finalement la date du salon
elle même a été décalé et donc nous
sommes aujourd'hui ici au mois de juin
mais je me suis posé la même question
est ce que je pourrais voyager à ce
moment là on devait vient de naître on
est début on est début juin donc il a
deux mois et demi finalement j'ai décidé
de venir mais j'ai failli annuler il ya
une semaine j'ai failli annuler mais
c'est en fait ça me fend des
complètement le coeur de laisser mon
petit bébé de deux mois même pour 48
heures et je me suis dit non je ne vais
plus je vais je vais je devoir annuler
et là en fait mon mari m'a dit non je
n'annule pas je viens avec toi et on
emmène le bébé donc il est là d'ailleurs
dans la salle également
et donc c'est ce qui fait que
aujourd'hui je suis là devant vous mais
c'est pour vous montrer qu'en fait c'est
souvent parce qu'on se met nous mêmes
nos propres barrières qu'on n'arrive pas
à faire certaines choses il faut
absolument enlevé de notre tête qu'on ne
peut pas faire les choses on peut tout
faire qu'on soit un homme ou une femme
d'ailleurs on peut tout faire tout est
possible mais tout dépend de ce qu'on
veut et la plupart du temps ce qui est
difficile c'est de savoir ce qu'on veut
parce qu'en général on fait un peu des
deux où on veut et mans le 15 12 veut
toujours tout est jeu
j'essaye tant bien que mal de le faire
on me dit souvent c'est pas possible en
fait de réussir à concilier les deux et
tu va sacrifier l'un ou l'autre tu va
sacrifier soit à vue professionnel soit
tu vas sacrifié ta vie ta vie
personnelle et en fait je pense que
c'est c'est pas vraiment la réponse à la
question sais pas comment je fais c'est
sais comment je gère parce qu'en fait
tout est une question de gestion
d'organisation et
de pouvoir être entouré ça c'est
vraiment primordial donc on est entouré
par sa famille en premier lieu on est
entouré par ses collègues on est entouré
par ses amis et aussi par la société qui
nous impose un certain nombre deux
choses quand on est une femme africaine
vivant dans un pays musulman notamment
mais je pense que il faut être conscient
de ses propres limites moi je me
souviens au début quand je voyageais
pour le travail j'étais à l'époque à
paris donc je travaillais pour un grand
cabinet international et avant de
rentrer en guinée je voyage énormément
déjà je travaille je voyageais dans
plusieurs pays africains et avant de
partir en voyage donc j'avais à l'époque
deux enfants je me mettais une pression
telle que en fait pour pouvoir me
déculpabiliser de voyager avant de
partir bas je préparais tout tout tout
remplissez le frigo je faisais à manger
pour qu'ils aient à manger pour la
semaine parce que sinon je vais mourir
de faim évidemment je préparais les
habits parce qu'en fait je voulais pas
que mes enfants à l'école habillé
n'importe comment je suis un peu psy quo
sur ce genre de choses jusqu'à
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs est en fait du
coup je choisisse et les tenues pour
tous les jours de mon absence de la
petite culotte petit t-shirt la chemise
le manteau locaux lan des chaussettes
tout autour et en fait je me suis rendu
compte que j'étais complètement folle en
fait voilà ce que c'est ça c'est pas
possible de continuer à le faire alors
avec 4 et 5 en france allait plus être
possible du tout de toute façon donc
j'ai arrêté j'ai arrêté j'ai arrêté
pourquoi parce qu en fait à un moment
j'ai fait un burn-out tout simplement un
vrai bon match c'était c'était assez
impressionnant ça m'est arrivé donc
j'étais rentré en guinée ça faisait
trois ans que j'étais installé en guinée
que je venais de monter mon cabinet qui
était en pleine explosion et je venais
d'avoir ma troisième fille est en fait
je me suis rendu compte que bunge avait
pas eu de congé maternité
forcément quand on travaille pour soi
mais on n'a pas de congé de maternité ça
c'est pas possible et donc c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut prendre quand si vous
voulez être entrepreneur avait déclaré
si vous voulez travailler à votre compte
en tant que femme on n'a pas de congé
maternité là j'en ai pas eu non plus et
à tel point que avant de d'accoucher à
mon médecin hospitalisée pendant 15
jours parce qu'il s'est dit dans dix
jours parce que il s'est dit si tu es
seul moyen de me faire arrêter de
travailler vous rendez compte ce
problème est assez grave donc j'étais
hospitalisé et il m'a dit plus
d'ordinateurs plus rien plus rien plus
rien et donc rangé mon troisième enfant
il s'est passé un peu la même chose j'ai
travaillé jusqu'à la veille de
l'accouchement jouera le jeu jusqu'au
jour même d'ailleurs et après j'ai eu
bébé et je continue à travailler avec
l'allaitement les téléphones ordinateurs
etc est ce que valent les clients en
fait ils n'arrêtent pas ils veulent
toujours en soit la continuer à répondre
à leurs attentes et quelques mois après
marge et ce qui devait arriver arriva je
me suis arrêté mon corps s'est arrêté
mais c'est un truc de fou parce que moi
je ne m'arrête jamais je suis une pile
électrique je m'arrête jamais je fais
tout tout tout tout en même temps et en
fait mon corps m'a dit simplement
massaly tu peux plus rien faire tu ne
peux plus rien faire mais ça s'appelle
l'asthénie médicalement c'est à dire que
je ne pouvais plus regardé mon
ordinateur je recevais un nouvel email
je pleurais parce que je me disais je
vais pas réussir à le faire je vais pas
réussir à traiter cette nouvelle demande
je déjà sous l'eau je sais pas je peux
pas y arriver et du coup à ce moment là
j'ai vraiment dû m'arrêter pendant
quelques temps j'ai appris mes plus gros
clients et je leur ai dit ben je vais
pas disponible pendant quelques temps je
suis pas malade je suis pas fin je suis
pas hospitalisée en tout cas il m'arrive
rien de deux absolument effrayant mais
je vais devoir m'arrêter un petit peu
pour pouvoir prendre du temps pour moi
et pour pouvoir me ressaisir et cet
épisode de ma vie professionnelle m'a
justement fait réaliser beaucoup de
choses et depuis je travaille
complètement différemment parce que j'ai
appris que justement il fallait prendre
conscience de ses propres limites et
justement les mettre au service de sa
famille les maîtres service de son
travail et mettre au service de 7,2 ses
amis différemment de la manière dont on
pense qu'on doit le faire en fait on
peut pas tout faire parfaitement il ya
des moments où on va décider de faire de
mettre en priorité certaines choses par
rapport à d'autres et ça c'est quelque
chose dont il faut vraiment prendre
conscience donc on gère on gère par
rapport à ses propres contraintes on
gère par rapport à son mode de vie donc
quand on regarde moi ça m'a toujours
impressionné ça quand on va faire les
courses au marché qu'on regarde les les
femmes qui ont leur étal de fruits et
légumes et qui ont ces enfants qui sont
à leur pied ou qui sont sur leur sein
mais en fait cette femme n'a fait avec
ses propres contraintes elle va
travailler en tenant compte de ces
contraintes à elles qui sont peut-être
qu'elle a pas de mode de garde
alternatif mais qu'il faut qu'elle
continue à gagner sa vie quand même donc
évidemment nous sommes pour la plupart
d'entre nous dans des situations très
très privilégié où on peut avoir de
l'aide à la maison et je pense que c'est
aussi une chance pour nous de vivre en
afrique par rapport à ça moi qui ai
connu les deux ans vivant en france
pendant les années où j'ai eu mes deux
premiers enfants c'était vraiment
vraiment vraiment très facile donc on a
quand même ce luxe en afrique de pouvoir
avoir le soutien que ce soit le soutien
du personnel de maison ou du le soutien
familial etc c'est vraiment à ne pas
négliger parce que je pense que c'est
aussi peut-être pour ça qu'on est aussi
forte nos femmes africaines parce qu'on
a ce tissu social qui est qu'il a autour
de nous donc je ne suis pas super buman
en fait c'est ce que je dis souvent et
ça nous
remet en cause beaucoup de choses en
fait quand on est confronté à ce type de
l'événement
l'autre chose dont je voulais parler
c'est
si soi même est ce qu'en fait il ya
quelque chose qu'on oublie souvent dans
tout ça c'est de s'occuper de soi donc
on va s'occuper de sa carrière on va
donner on va se donner à fond dans sa
carrière on va également s'occuper de
ses enfants donc on me donnait un
exemple ce matin je parlais avec une de
mes collaboratrices qui me disait
qu'elle a une amie qu il ya eu un enfant
il n'y a pas très longtemps et que cet
ami en fait c'est complètement oublié
parce qu'elles continuent à les
travailler avant de chez elle elle
s'occupe de son enfant et elle du coup
elle ne prend pas du tout de temps pour
elle parce qu'elle elle culpabilise
c'est toujours non le problème qu'on a
en tant que femme on culpabilise de tout
est en fait du coup cette cette femme
elle et elle se sent misérable parce que
finalement si on s'oublie soi même mais
on peut pas être là pour les autres donc
ça c'est aussi nos des leçons que j'ai
retenu de montbernard il faut vraiment
pouvoir continuer à s'occuper de soi
quelles que soient les circonstances et
se préserver des moments où on fait des
choses qui nous font plaisir où on voit
nos amis où on va se faire les ongles on
va ce préfet où on fait du sport je fais
beaucoup de sport personnellement je me
disais c'est aussi quelque chose qui m'a
beaucoup aidé pendant ma grossesse de
continuer à faire beaucoup de yoga
beaucoup de pilates ça permet de rester
entrée en soi et d'avoir ainsi des
moments où on réfléchit à ce qu'on veut
comment on veut faire les choses et ça
c'est un message spécialement pour les
jeunes femmes qui sont dans le public
aujourd'hui c'est c'est très important
de ne pas s'oublier
j'ai aussi des messages pour les hommes
parce qu'en fait quand on parle de vie
privée ne vie professionnelle souvent
les hommes eux c'est évident privilégie
la vie professionnelle ben en fait
souvent ces hommes là ils en payent le
prix d'un peu plus tard dans leur
enfance son adolescence et qu'ils n'ont
pas été forcément très présent pour eux
ils s'en sont pas forcément beaucoup
occupés qu'ils ont laisser à la maman le
ce rôle là donc je pense que c'est aussi
très important quand on est un homme de
justement regarder également ce qui se
passe à la maison d'un peu plus près et
de ne pas être
touristes sa maison je pense que c'est
très important
et êtes-vous jeune femme qui nous met
pas encore mariés également quelques
conseils
choisissez bien votre mari très très
important
peut-être qu'il faut absolument que
notre mari puisse vous soutenir et vous
accompagner dans ce que vous faites je
parle de votre mari ça peut être votre
soeur ça peut être votre famille mais il
faut que votre environnement vous
accompagne parce que sinon ça ne
fonctionne pas en fait un peut pas y
arriver tout seul donc je vais conclure
sur ces quelques mots c'est que on est
au salon donc de l'entrepreneuriat au
stade m on a deux jours magnifiques
devant nous et je pense que
l'entrepreneuriat c'est vraiment cette
liberté qu'on a moi c'est ce que j'ai
retenu c'est que quand on est
entrepreneur on est libre on est libre
de pouvoir mettre le curseur où on veut
au moment où on le veut ça veut pas dire
que on fait tout en même temps mais il
ya des moments où on va décider que le
curseur c'est la vie professionnelle il
ya des moments où j'ai décidé que le
curseur c'est la vie personnelle moi ce
que j'aime dans l'entrepreneuriat c'est
que on est flexible on peut gérer sa
journée de manière complètement
flexibles moi je travaille beaucoup de
matin est souvent très très tard le soir
l'après midi c'est un peu plus difficile
pour moi de travailler parce que j'ai
les enfants qui sont revenus à la maison
et donc du coup c'est vraiment la clé je
pensais c'est d'être libre d'être libre
par rapport à soi surtout merci
[Applaudissements]